You've passed this as an independent game developer.
The night is haunting. And those programming errors.
It seems that the first game will achieve great success for you, very far away.
I've heard about the legend: Indie Games Accelerator
... It's a Google Play program, from which independent developers send their ideas to life ...
... and they design epic games and great adventures that people love.
The selected participants are transferred to Google Asia headquarters in Singapore ...
... where they receive direct training from the best mobile gaming experts in the world, ...
... and some amazing rewards like Google Pixel phones, Google Cloud balance, and exclusive event invites!
Missed your chance the previous time?
Start your engines, because a new adventure is about to begin!
Applications for the 2019 category of Indie Games Accelerator are now open ...
... This is your chance to grow your business on Google Play.
Now welcome to the game developers of the selected countries ...
... in Latin America, Africa, the Middle East and Asia - who look to improve the performance of their games ...
... and reach new heights.
Apply for the program today and upgrade your game to the next level!